[Music]
let's go to john in fort mill
south carolina what's up john
hey john how you doing i'm good my
brother how are you
i'm doing very well i love listening to
your show thanks man i appreciate it
what's up
so uh
i've been married for about six to seven
years um
and when i got married we were on the
same path of having kids
and about a year and a half to two years
ago
my wife has come to me and says that she
does not want kids
and i have been struggling with when i
came up i was like well do i really want
kids and so i questioned whether i want
kids and recently i've determined that i
do want kids
so i'm at a crutch of whether i choose
kids or whether i choose my wife and i
don't know what direction and kind of
how to to make that decision
that's hard man i'm sorry
it's a little tricky yeah
um
yeah it's one of those um yeah your path
forward is really simple just like diet
and exercise man that's how you lose
weight like well thanks dude right
um
so if you and i were just like having a
drink eating chips and queso my next
question would be so you already know
what you're gonna do so what are you
going to do
oh
still you know
you know
you know what are you going to do
i mean i really want kids but i i
struggle
i'm also you know faith-based so i
struggle with divorce and leaving my
wife behind
so i struggle with that a lot has she
left you behind
uh
a little bit in this decision yes she
has
this isn't a little decision this is an
identity shape-shifter decision
yeah
and she's allowed to change her mind
and you're allowed to be put in a really
awkward situation right
yes yeah so what are you gonna do
well i've talked to a lot of people i've
gotten several advice from several
people okay hold on so we're in an age
now where it feels like the greatest um
the greatest antidote to anxiety is more
data
more information i'm gonna have one more
cup of coffee i'm gonna make one more
call i'm gonna have one more meeting
what are you gonna do john
i
i don't know i think the best that's
where i'm at crutch because i love her
so much
and
then but i want kids so i'm going to
grieve one thing or the other so whether
if i grave her or i agree with a kid
there's going to be something that i'm
going to grieve right
can you stay in relationship with this
woman and not resent her
[Music]
i think i i won't resent her because
um
i'm telling you right now john you're
gonna have to work real real hard
every time you go to the grocery store
and there's two kids in a stroller and
one's being goofy and one's being silly
you're gonna have to exhale
yeah
because that could be hard
right it's hard i've been yeah i've been
dealing with that for the past year or
so every time you drive by a little
league game you're gonna have to exhale
yeah
because that's what you all agreed on
and then things changed
yeah
right
yeah that's definitely what we agreed on
and then things changed can you do that
um
it's a challenge i've been trying to do
it for the past year because i found out
about a year
about a year ago
um that kids were off the table and so
i've been trying to do that and
kindly our relationship it's hard to put
a significant amount of work into the
relationship knowing this
but i'm trying to
put that to the side and put a lot of
effort into relationship even though
this is you know a portion of
you know something that we're dealing
with so i want to
this is one of those issues that i can't
quantify i don't have any scientific
studies
a few things way
in an identity sense
like are we gonna have kids or not
so you this is not like hey i want to
live in a condo in the city and hey i
want to live on two acres in the country
this isn't that
this is core
okay so i don't want you to minimize
this i want you to let this overwhelm
you with the grief that it is it's huge
big
right
yeah it definitely is and the one
question i i you know i still
say there's hope
to to potentially have one and you know
there's still that big shadow of having
a kid but i still
you know i i don't know i don't want to
create hope where there's no hope um it
sounds like she was really
kind to you
in her clarity
uh
not really i don't feel like i don't
feel like it was a dual decision okay um
so and i've tried to get empathy from
her
the past month or two about you know
grieving a
child and
it typically ends up talking about
separation and divorce you know she
doesn't want me not to have kids and
she's willing to separate it's just okay
so hold on hold on i was getting there
and then i got sidetracked
what's really underneath this
i i mean the talks of separation and
divorce are are definitely right there
there's no i mean my guess is all these
conversations were going on before she
dropped this on you
is this her is this her out yeah
i don't know
yes you do john yes you do is this her
out
i mean it could be i mean it could be
her out she could put it on hey this is
he i don't want to have kids and and you
know i'm i'm ready to give up on the
relationship because she i mean there's
things in our relationship that we both
struggle with on 100 like what like what
um so we've been going to therapy almost
every week for about a year
to deal with stuff and
um you know she feels that she doesn't
feel wanted in our relationship which is
pretty big okay
um
and so
that's one of the reasons why she says
she doesn't want to have kids and also
she just doesn't want to have kids
because she also has other issues she
deals with depression and anxiety so
those are big things that she deals with
why doesn't she feel like you value her
uh cause
because there's probably some times
where i don't show that
um
in in her and that's what i've been
trying to get back to that to show her
that i do value her i don't know if it's
too little too late
yeah i'm not sure here's what i'm
hearing from you or here's what i'm not
hearing from you
and i want you to when you listen back
to this
um no i'm an old counseling i mean an
old college professor okay and so when
someone would come in and be like this
is the right way to do fill in the blank
i always my job as a college professor
was to hit the other side of that scale
okay
so
i'm not going to tell you what to do i'm
just trying to push buttons and see
where you land
and
here's why i have not heard
i haven't heard a guy who in a
counseling session when his wife bears
her soul and says
i don't feel like you want me and i'm
not bringing a kid into this
that you don't
take a knee
and hold her hand
and say i'm ready to storm the gates of
hell for you
i'm gonna fight for this i'm gonna
change everything
i'm gonna change my clothes my job my
life because you are
my partner in this deal
i hear a guy going well you know i'm
gonna work on it i'm gonna
i'm gonna call a guy and we're gonna go
get some beers and we'll uh oh yeah
we're gonna figure it out
uh
that's what i hear
and for a woman who's struggling with
anxiety what you just heard the last
call it's connection it's safety and
it's autonomy control
yeah well you know i'm thinking about it
i'm gonna um
i'm gonna really i'm gonna work on it
and uh
i will
fight for you
i need you to explain i want you to
write down your needs
how can i touch you how can i welcome
you how can i help around the house
how can i love you and it's not sexy and
it's not you know titanic and there's no
music that's gonna swell but this is you
helping coach me how i can love you and
i am all
in
you talk like that and more importantly
you act you back it up you change your
actions there
now you're talking about an entirely
different household
you're talking about a wife who can
breathe her wife who feels anchored into
something safe not something that's like
i don't know man let's go lift the truck
something that is
in rock
right and here's my expectation that she
does the same thing for you that she
looks at you and says john i am all all
in
you write down your needs and i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna storm hell to try to
make these needs happen for you
because i want you to feel loved too and
you deserve that
also okay it sounds like you all may
have one of those
marriage counselors where there's a lot
of talk and a lot of dancing
and there's no taking sides and there's
no let's get to some solutions here
that's what uh that's what we struggle
with that's we actually kind of
took a little bit of a pause good go
find a different one go find a different
counselor and walk in the door and say
we're at a crossroads here we're talking
divorce we're talking separation my wife
doesn't feel loved and i don't have the
tools to show her how much she means to
me
and i wanted to have kids we talked
about it and she has said she'd want to
bring kids into this relationship and
into her mental health challenges
and we need help we need actionable help
go challenge a therapist with that and
there are some extraordinary therapists
who will rise up and meet that challenge
but you got to be that clear okay
okay
here's how we end this today
i want
i want you to a know probably probably
this isn't about kids it might be
ten years from now if you choose to stay
in this marriage and you're like wow i
really thought we were having kids she's
gonna point back and be like i was
pretty super clear
but the more you and i talked the more
maybe she wasn't
right
and so the call's less about kids the
calls about a marriage that's not
falling apart
it's slowly leaking out the bottom of
the drain
yeah right and you slowly run out of
oxygen and so you're getting
light-headed and you're finding yourself
gulping for air and you're wondering
what happened what happened what
happened
i don't believe in too late
i believe at any point two grown adults
can look at each other and say i'm going
back all in
i believe that with all my heart i've
seen it happen
um
but somebody has to go first and so it
starts with you so today looks like this
when she gets home from wherever she's
at today
you say i'm sorry
i'm fighting for this i'm fighting for
you
i love you and we're gonna figure out
how i'm going to commit the rest of my
life to meeting your needs in any way i
possibly can
are you in with me and here's what she
might say brother she might say no
and you got to take that risk
because the other end of that equation
is she might say yes
she might say yes
and then in two years after you all have
got two years of practicing each other's
needs and meeting each other's needs and
what love looks like and what connection
looks like and what marriage looks like
and what sex and intimacy looks like all
those things you're starting to practice
those things and you're back in it
you're back in it you're back in it
you're back in it
then you can call my show and say hey i
want you to meet listen to john jr here
or you may call back and say hey i went
all in on my wife and um at the end of
the day i really wanted kids
but don't make either of those decisions
without at least going all in
go all in